bonjour à tous soyez les bienvenus à
chacun son explication d'un côté
l'Ukraine qui dément être responsable
des attaques sur Moscou l'année dernière
et Poutine qui accuse l'Ukraine de
vouloir terrifier la population russe
pour le Président il s'agit d'une
riposte à une frappe que la Russie a
mené sur le QG du renseignement
militaire ukrainien Bruno darrouve nous
avait rejoint on est en pleine guerre là
d'informationnelle oui alors
complètement ce qui est un peu étonnant
c'est que Vladimir Poutine réagit quand
même à cette attaque de drone au
sud-ouest de Moscou il accuse donc les
autorités ukrainiennes de vouloir
terrifier la population russe alors que
d'après différents témoignages provenant
de Moscou dans le centre de la capitale
en tout cas il y a pas vraiment eu de
panique et en même temps
il dit que la défense anti-aérienne
russe a fonctionné de manière
satisfaisante donc c'est à la fois un
commentaire un peu alarmant et puis dans
minutes qui suit tout à fait qui se veut
tout à fait rassurant mais bien sûr
c'est pour faire passer le message que
les Ukrainiens de plus en plus s'en
prennent au territoire russe et que
c'est totalement irresponsable et que ça
peut constituer évidemment une escalade
évidemment c'est un message à
destination de Kiev mais aussi des
alliés
occidentaux de l'Ukraine qui ne veulent
pas que l'Ukraine s'en prenne au
territoire de la Russie alors c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que l'Ukraine de son côté
à chaque fois dit qu'elle n'est
absolument pas responsable de ces
attaques de drone qu'elle constate qu'il
y a des attaques en territoire russe
mais que si on comprend bien elle ne
sait pas trop de d'où ça vient bon alors
chacun joue une sorte de poker menteur
qui confirme néanmoins qu'on est sans
doute soit dans les débuts de la
contre-offensive
ukrainienne à laquelle se prépare aussi
la Russie soit dans les prémices de
cette contre-offensive que de part et
d'autre il y a une volonté d'essayer de
nuire dis ons aux capacités de
l'adversaire par voilà des des envois de
drone domiciles en visant aussi
évidemment des cibles comme les dépôts
de munitions bien évidemment et que
voilà peut-être que bientôt on va
rentrer dans une phase plus plus directe
plus terrestre de cette contre-offensive
merci